despite severus snape scaring the slugs
out of the kid actors alan rickman had a
heart of gold and an upward battle in
front of him to dispel that terrifying
mystique let's get started everyone it's
time to turn to page 394
everybody loves a good fart joke and
that includes the dark arts teacher at
hogwarts or should we say dark farts
teacher ah maybe not excuse us so here's
how the real scene went down for in
dreams we enter a world that's entirely
our own
let them swim in the deepest ocean
alright now let's check out this awesome
prank instigated by alan rickman in our
dreams
we enter completely our own world
see the blush on danny's face really
really funny and for you that's because
his crush was curled up into a sleeping
bag next to him we like to we like to
swim
in the deepest waters
this is one of those you said it not me
moments
we're so annoying
seeing rickman smile in costume is a
rare occurrence but radcliffe calling
himself and the other child actors
annoying sure brought a smile to his
face despite the playful banter rickman
loves kids and always wanted to have
kids of his own he figured he just had
to settle for the cast of kids in harry
potter instead
now this is probably the most
heartwarming thing rickman ever did
imagine having severus snape himself
advocate for you to be part of the
magical world of harry potter well
that's exactly what happened with a 15
year old boy named jay who was battling
stage four neuroblastoma when alan
rickman in character asked
why isn't this child in the film
and took jay by the hand and placed him
in the crowd of kids supposedly this was
the scene they were filming at the time
but unfortunately the take wasn't used
in the film
either way it still would have been
pretty magical to find yourself in the
middle of the cast of harry potter
ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Music]
now let's get into the juicy stuff did
you know rickman almost quit the
franchise after the second movie he
wasn't happy with the lack of
progression in his character and didn't
want to keep playing the evil type for
evil's sake and joe rowling hadn't
finished writing the books at the time
so rickman had no idea what was in store
for snape come the end of the series
rowling told him a secret that changed
everything for him and he never spilled
the secret to anyone there was more to
him than met to the eye while rowling
has revealed on twitter she told him
what lies behind the word
what exactly she said is still a mystery
but we've got some pretty good theories
do you have any idea what that secret
might be
kids will be kids and as it turns out
onset classrooms can be pretty darn
close to the real thing rupert grint is
pretty lucky that alan rickman isn't as
humorless as his film persona though
while filming a potion lesson scene he
drew a caricature of rickman as i was
drawing it allen rickman was standing
right behind me and i was so scared
honestly we would be too rubert
especially if it's as nasty as we're
imagining it to be i made him sign it
and i have it in my possession
did you know alan rickman actually
studied graphic design so yeah he knows
good art when he sees it
the only thing more confusing than magic
is technology oliver phelps taught the
dark arts teacher a thing or two about
it after he was gifted an ipod the best
part was while they filmed the great
hall scenes rickman tried to hide the
thing under his robe and wig
don't worry this costume was washed it
just never changed while alan rickman
wanted a character that developed and
progressed he felt exactly the opposite
about his costume
good luck today potter
of course
rickman even got a say in the design of
his costume i said the sleeves should be
really tight and there should be a lot
of buttons the costume department never
told him that they had to loosen
everything a bit after he returned from
holidays honestly that was kind of nice
of them we can't say we would want to
know either
once rickman puts on the severus snape
wardrobe he immediately drops into
character maybe it's something to do
with those tight sleeves or buttons
maybe it's the hair it's gotta be that
heavy cape slowing him down and raising
his schna's
we're not sure but anyway it's super
intimidating while alan in costume made
all of the child actors nervous he
always had a little troupe of children
visiting the set and when he sat down to
lunch with them he would have to throw a
big old bib on top to protect his
costume
it would pretty much destroy that
intimidating aura
young old or anything in between alan
rickman never saw that as a reason to
look down on somebody else upon his
passing daniel radcliffe said as an
actor he was one of the first adults on
potter to treat me like a peer rather
than a child on alan's last day of
filming matthew lewis approached rickman
to say thank you
specifically to say thank you for not
once in 10 years ever shouting at me or
you know treating any of us
anything less than your equal
there's no reason to cry over a spilled
milkshake unless of course you spill
that milkshake in alan rickman's car
we think it's perfectly reasonable that
he banned rupert grint and matthew lewis
from being within 5 meters of his brand
new bmw after the milkshake mishap that
happened a year earlier who do you think
did it honestly for us it's a toss-up
between the two
alan rickman's eyes aren't naturally
black surprise
they're actually a soulful less
intimidating hazel color so to darken
them up he had to wear contacts
throughout the entire filming process
when mike newell joined the team as the
director of goblet of fire he
complemented the richness of rickman's
eyes and he responded by popping out one
of the lenses
allen constantly found himself impressed
by the sets in harry potter
he never stopped being fascinated by
picking up my wand and poking the wall
we wonder if this admiration comes down
to his graphic design training
[Music]
the actor that we think is oliver phelps
recalls a pretty funny and yet
simultaneously terrifying moment when
snape hit ron on the back of the head
with a book oliver couldn't help but
giggle which is totally on brand for the
character to laugh at his little brother
but remembers having that smile wiped
off his face when he got the eye from
snape a totally unplanned moment i kind
of think that my god is going to hit me
as well
[Music]
did you know alan rickman was a bank
thief okay he robbed green god's bank it
isn't exactly the worst crime in the
world by the end of filming on the first
day at gringotts rickman had nabbed all
the coins that isn't his only successful
moment of stealing either he stole some
of those letters that the owls brought
and sold them online one of which he got
25 000 bucks for
speaking of maggie smith rickman
admitted to having a huge admiration for
her as he used to watch her perform on
the national theater stage so when their
big performances together relied mostly
on cgi he found it just a bit awkward
holding a wand is not the most
threatening thing
the word that gets passed around the
most from cast members and friends is
that alan rickman was a generous human
being and that pretty much sums him up
perfectly doesn't it now we have one
question to send us out what do you
think he was listening to on his ipod
thanks for watching